I made the decision to make this my last
season as co-host with Kell here on Live
with Kelly and Ryan which is Bittersweet
Ryan Seacrest is officially saying
goodbye to Live with Kelly and Ryan
after six seasons on the morning show it
is a rare thing to work with a guy who
is so authentic and fun and joyful and
humble and generous and kind to everyone
and now Kelly who's hosted the show
since 2001 will have a familiar new
co-host the only person I can think of
that is capable of you know holding
holding your torch the way you have held
it and that would be my husband Mark
Consuelos
Ryan made the announcement during
Thursday's show revealing he plans to
head back to California where he'll
remain a part of the ABC entertainment
family hosting American Idol and Dick
Clark's New Year's Rockin Eve you are
one of my best friends and I said like
the greatest part of this entire
experience has been that you've gone
from being a a friend to a family member
Ryan was named Kelly's permanent co-host
on live back in May 2017 replacing
Michael Strahan there is a significant
level of I know respect I have for Kelly
and trust and I think that's important
Ryan explains that he originally
committed to three years on the show but
he had so much fun he stuck around a
little longer three turned into six
because of the genuine fun of being on
this television show every hour of every
weekday I love you so much now a source
tells E.T that Ryan has contemplated
leaving the show for years and has been
very conflicted adding that he truly
loves working with Kelly and the Live
Crew but with all his other commitments
he felt leaving the show was the right
thing to do
in 2020 Ryan suffered from exhaustion
and was burnt out and he's trying to
avoid that from happening again with
Ryan exiting the show will be rebranded
to Live with Kelly and Mark with Kell's
long time love and frequent guest
co-host taking the gig good morning hey
Mark Consuelos is here everybody
it's a choice that ET Source says was
easy the network in Kelly wanted to
avoid her and a new co-host not hitting
it off Mark feel free to uh redesign the
dressing room in a couple of months all
right we don't
compete with each other we don't have
egos where the other person is concerned
we are like we have each other's backs
following the announcement Ryan posted
several snaps with Kelly writing that
he'll miss his work wife I learned so
much from her not just by being on the
air but about life I mean she's a
remarkable colleague the most amazing
mother and wife and I get to see all
sides of that as for Mark he wrote on
Instagram that he knows he has some big
shoes to fill meanwhile Kelly shared
this pic with Ryan and Mark Writing in
the caption that she'll forever be in
Ryan's corner he just brings a
joyfulness and enthusiasm of
professionalism and an authenticity to
this place and when it comes to her
hubby she joked welcome home or to the
contractual obligation phase of our
relationship
foreign